[Music]
all right let's go to michelle in
pensacola florida good morning michelle
what's going on
i'm doing great how are you we are just
saving the world
what's up
um so i i was a previous caller um about
my daughter you had given me some advice
in the past uh we were awaiting a
diagnosis
yes hey so first let me say this
did i screw it up the first time
no you did not screw it up okay good i
was hoping you weren't calling me to
tell me i was an idiot and
um
so you were one of the first callers one
of the ogs way back in the day
yes i was on one of your first shows i
was so excited about that
and it's just continued to go
since then but hey thanks for hanging
with us
uh okay so you called and you had
let give us a reminder of what was going
on
so my daughter she was two at the time
and there were some delays going on and
i called asking for some advice because
you know i was worried that
i
wasn't doing enough for her to make sure
that she was where she needed to be
kind of just you know in an uncertain
spot so you
helped me through that and you know
found my community where we were but we
have some sun relocated because we are a
military family
and we also have gotten an official
diagnosis for cadence as well okay so
what's the diagnosis
so she actually has a it's a somewhat
rare genetic condition
and
it causes epilepsy which we got the
official diagnosis for that
uh back in april so we she's having
silent seizures
and it also along with that
are uh
there's an intellectual delay there's
she still doesn't talk she's almost four
she'll be four in november
and she's got a movement disorder as
well so she's
quite a clumsy child yeah so
with the
um is the epilepsy disorder is that
really the
are the doctors saying that's the root
and these other things are derivative
um so it's actually the epilepsy is
derivative of the
genetic condition that we just got the
diagnosis of the genetic condition uh
last month okay all right and you've got
a little one too
yes so
eden is nine months old now
because why not right why not relocate
in the middle of a pandemic plus get
your special needs diagnostics for your
little one and then have a
nine-month-old
yeah just go all in
wow okay so
tell me how that's going
uh it's going great cadence is an
amazing big sister it's so hard with her
not being you know not being able to
communicate but
she
she loves eden she comes over she gives
eating kisses all the time when i'm
feeding her
she plays with her like she's she's
doing so well and there were so many
uh you know worries that i had in my
mind because people kept telling me how
terrible cadence is going to take it but
they were wrong
yes and so you just told me something
important i know we haven't even got to
your question yet
there's a difference between
non-communicative and non-verbal and so
your daughter may not be speaking yet
but she's
truly communicating a lot is that fair
it is yeah it's definitely fair it just
looks much different than what i
expected there you go all right so
what's your question
yeah so kind of you know what they just
said um i i feel
bad that sometimes i feel this way
but
i mean these girls they're my whole
world but sometimes it's
it feels like i am grieving
what i expected motherhood to look like
you know with everything going on with
cadence that
i feel like i'm constantly kind of on
edge and you know worried and
keeping an extra extra close eye on her
almost like i'm waiting for the other
shoe to drop
and i think that i am just struggling to
sometimes take a deep breath
and try to enjoy the moment a little bit
more
so can you do me a huge favor
yes will you
redo that whole thing
i'm gonna ask you the question
okay and you
apologized and
minimized before you even said what's
going on in your heart and head
and i want you to rephrase it and i want
you to tell me exactly no no
i'm afraid i'm gonna get found out or
i'm afraid someone i'm not allowed to
say these things i'm a mom i'm supposed
to feel i want you to tell me what's
actually going on in your heart and head
is that cool
that's cool okay so we'll hit rewind and
for those of you who don't know where
rewind is because you're young it's this
thing we used to do with tapes and it
was incredible so we'll rewind and then
so hey so what's going on michelle let's
go tell me what's going on what'd you
call
hey
i'm going because
i am struggling with the fact that
motherhood
is turning out differently than what i
always imagined okay let's rewind and do
it again hey michelle what's going on
be more honest
okay uh hey dr d i'm doing great uh no
rewind again i'll i'll help you
hey dr d i'm so pissed off
that my two-year-old has all these
physical and um disability challenges
i am super pissed that all my friends
kids seem to be all perfect and on
instagram everything's going great
i'm so pissed that i just can't hug my
nine-year-old without worrying that
my two and a half year old is going to
fall down or my three-year-old's gonna
have some issue
i'm so pissed that we had to move again
and i love that we're in the military
but god almighty can we just get some
community is that closer to you
yeah much closer too
and i hate that for you
i hate that somebody told you you're not
allowed to feel your feelings right now
i hate that somebody told you that
um
oh by the way your daughter's gonna
screw up everything so don't worry you
know all that stuff you're carrying so
tell me where you're where you're really
truly at i also did a really annoying
thing which i want to call out that
i'm some
man that you've never met telling you
what your feelings are out loud i just
did that and that was pretty lame of me
um
you give me your own words what are you
experiencing
um
so in my own words i think it's
i mean you kind of hit it right on the
head um you know i'm seeing
my friends do all these different things
with their children and
it's things that i would love to do with
cadence but we're not able to or
you know we attempt to and the outcome
isn't
exactly what
you know that exactly what i wanted it
to be here what i thought it would be
like
you know even as
as well as going and taking her to
do something that i think she would have
fun doing and
um
she ends up not enjoying it or it's just
a bad day and
it's just
not
not what i i thought that it would be
are any of these things rolling off that
you're a bad mom
like this is on you this is your fault
um a little bit i've been working
through that for a long time
um i feel like that's that's kind of
been
in my head since cadence started missing
her milestones you know and she was just
a baby
so some of the with some of the the
parents i've worked with over the years
i've seen it over and over where
their kid is born with a genetic issue
or with a learning disability or some
sort of challenge
and then
mom and or dad often mom sometimes dad
own this as though this is our fault
something about us created this child
with these challenges
and then it becomes super your job to
make sure that they are catching up
whatever that means that they are having
super tons of fun whatever that means
and with kids with special needs they
don't always have fun in traditional
ways they don't communicate in
traditional ways they do things
differently the the circus may scare the
crap out of them or they may be too
short to ride the roller coaster for a
long time or whatever the thing is
and that just compounds this ceaseless
never-ending guilt so am i on the right
track there
you are okay and then you get pissed
at your kid that they're not having fun
or you get mad at your friend and then
you feel guilty about getting mad or you
feel guilty about
it's just this never-ending cycle of
guilt is that is that fair yes
it is it's very fair ugh
so
have you said out loud i hate this
i have not okay i need you to to know
it's okay to say that
in fact you have to
if you don't acknowledge how you truly
feel
there will be a widening gap between the
problems your body is trying to solve
for you
and this facade this fake universe
you're trying to create where it's
different but it's okay you know what i
mean
and it's not okay
it's not
it's not how we drew it up
right
and then we got to deal with the and
this is what is this is the reality
how's your husband doing with this
uh he's he's doing
okay you know we've had these
discussions where
well before we got the diagnosis for
cadence it was a lot of you know what
what are you most worried about and
a lot of times it always came back to
you know what if it is progressive or
degenerative and i prayed and prayed and
prayed and luckily this condition is not
that so
i i'm so grateful for that and so i
think that's part of where some of the
gold comes from too because
it could be worse so i try to minimize
what it truly is
and you know comparing grief
just takes your soul from me
yeah yeah could never compare grief like
oh my mom passed away but she was 70 so
i had more time than my friend's mom
man your mom passed away right so it's
just sitting in that hard stuff
um have you all had a
i'll just say this this is this isn't
related to your question but i think
it's important to have those type of
conversations with some regularity
good for you guys y'all are way ahead of
the curve for having this conversation
before she was born
but i think it's good to have check-in
conversations every couple of months
just how's our experience how are you
right
you know what i mean to check back in
because this whole all these milestones
are going to be different now
um so what's your question question i
feel like i'm talking too much what's
your question question
you're not talking too much
um i think
my question question is how do i
how do i just live more in the moment
without having to feel so heavy all of
the time
ah that's such a good question
so i want you to think of that weight
you feel that inability to breathe
as your body trying to experience the
reality of what you're living in
versus what your head is trying to
convince yourself is actually going on
what i mean by that is your body knows
that your daughter's hurting
your body knows that
it wants to be over here with your
special needs daughter and with your
nine month old
your body knows oh by the way i'm
supposed to fill in the blank around the
house and whatever and at work and with
my husband all that stuff and your
head's trying to say yeah but it could
be worse so we're all okay everybody
just smile let's get in the minivan
let's go you know what i mean there's a
gap yeah and so think of that weight
that head i love that use that word that
heaviness
as and it's gonna sound so cheesy please
don't roll your eyes
as unfelt feelings that you gotta
acknowledge are there
and instead of
trying to pretend they're not real i
want you to enter into an intentional
space of i'm going to feel sad for the
next hour
i'm going to be intentional about it
and for me i write that stuff down and
it doesn't work for everybody some
people need to say it out loud and tell
a friend
you've heard me say a million times
grief demands a witness and so having
somebody you can say
i hate all of this
and
i love love love being a mom and i love
my babies and i love that i was chosen
to be the person to navigate all of this
nobody else could do this and love these
kids like i can
and i hate that i got this assignment
you know what i mean
yeah so it's both and and if you try to
blow past one or the other then your
body's gonna wear it
and it doesn't mean it's all gonna be
roses but you will go through life
lighter you'll hold it looser and so
we're all going to the circus today and
you get to the circus and cadence has
just an absolute barn burner meltdown or
she has a seizure six six minutes in and
you gotta leave um you'll hold that
loosely instead of
i didn't worry it will be a loosely held
well we gave it a good shot and now
we're gonna go
take care of this this and this and this
and we're gonna be able to turn the
corner there
right
what does
feeling that look like for you
um
i feel like
feeling that probably is just
taking some time to really just sit
there and i probably just need to cry
out for a little bit because i try not
to do that
yeah please don't please don't hold that
in
um a lot of times the grief swirls
around inside of us
and getting it out
letting it be heard whether you write it
down tell somebody that's important i
can sit and stew for a long time and
like have a quote unquote quiet time
whatever that means and i come away more
fried than
when before i went in
if i don't sit down and write stuff out
and actually put it down on paper
um
hang on a second kelly would you be
willing to weigh in here
yeah sure um the main thing that i would
say hold on michelle
tell michelle your situation so michelle
we have um two special needs kids one
far more than the other um our daughter
has spina bifida she has
she's 18 but she's only about five
developmentally and there's also some
mental illness
so
quite a bit going on there the one thing
that i would say because you talked
about how there's certain things
that your your daughter can't do certain
things you know those kind of places we
wanted to take the family and things
that we wanted to do
there's a fine line between
we do these things as a family together
because this is what everyone can do
but also
knowing that
it's okay for you to get her a sitter
sometimes and take your other kids to do
those things
okay does that make sense
yeah okay
we do that often like we took our
daughter to disney
and it was all it was awful it did not
go well day one she looked at me like
five minutes in and said i want to go
home it's like great we have seven days
left awesome
and we
can't go home so we know that we're
probably going to go next year she won't
go she hated it it was awful for
everyone nobody had a good time so
she'll probably go to my in-laws where
she has their undivided attention for
you know six seven days and that's her
idea of
heaven yeah
and you know we want to take our son to
the beach well the wheelchair doesn't go
really well over the beach over the sand
so
she has camps that she goes to as well
that's something we can talk about off
air but the camps are great in the
summer and then when we use that time to
take our son somewhere else so you can
still do those things with your other
children
and and that's okay too because they
need to have those quote unquote normal
experiences as well
okay that makes a lot of sense thank you
so much for sharing that with me of
course and kelly can you
because i all of mine is theoretical i
haven't sat in the seat
um
what wisdom would you give to michelle
about those days when you're just pissed
off
that
um you've got hurting kids or that you
just want to be able to go on a date and
not have to deal with fill in the blank
yeah
there are days you're going to be pissed
i mean there's we've had our daughter we
adopted our daughter 13 years ago and
i've still pissed half the time
because it's not what we thought was
going to happen it's not what we thought
was going to be
and my husband and i know that it's okay
for me to
you know gripe to him and him to gripe
to me
because that's our safe space to do that
and i've also got a group of friends i
can do that with and they know that
because i know that if anybody outside
heard me i would sound like a horrible
human being for some of the things that
i gripe about
and but that's okay if you have that
safe place that you can do that with
your spouse and then i really recommend
a group of girlfriends too that will let
you do that without thinking wow she's
awful because they just know you're in a
crap situation and there's just no way
around it it sucks but you have to have
those and you have to have those outlets
to talk about it and then you have to
laugh at really really inappropriate
things
you know because you're just like you
have to because if not you'll just cry
all the time that's why kelly's perfect
this particular show
yeah because you just have to laugh and
you're like
i just
our life is stupid but you know what
it's ours and there's some great times
in it and there's some really really
hard times but you have to find great
sitters that you know can handle your
child so you can go get out there's
churches in our area that do what they
call respite nights
um
our church does one once a month where
our kids get to go and we get to have a
date night for free
so there are things like that you can
find to offer those little oasises kind
of in the desert that you're that you're
in
if you you have to look for them but
don't um isolate yourself because then
you'll just
be under your bed in the fetal position
yes which is where i usually am after
this show after kelly's talking in my
ear too
hey um thanks so much kelly hey michelle
will you do me a huge favor two things
yeah number one
be honest with yourself
okay okay don't hide from you
and that's such a temptation you are
allowed to have your feelings
and it's both hand
and obviously you got to get up and make
sure everybody's fed make sure
everybody's loved and go figure out what
the day is going to look like it's not
one or the other and we live in a
culture that says you do one of the
other you just led by your feelings and
if you feel sad you just yolo and sit in
bed and watch netflix
and then the other side of it is
a good mom whatever that means looks
like this whatever that means and you
are always feeling less than so you
want you to take permission to feel how
you feel
um and love how you love
and you gotta get up and do the right
thing
the second thing is is kelly mentioned
it please get a gang and i know that's
so hard in a military family where
you're moving and moving and moving and
moving um but continue to reach out
continue to reach out and make sure you
got a crew around you is that cool okay
that's cool i can do that and call us
back now you're now you're like in the
fam so call us back and we'll just keep
going on especially because in like a
couple of years there's gonna be some
knucklehead little kid thinking
constance is so your daughter's so
beautiful
and we'll tell you how to
get in a fight with a six-year-old right
my husband already taught her how to
shake her head no when he said he'll
he'll tell her he'll say what do you say
when all the boys say they want kisses
and she'll shake her head and say no no
no that
[Laughter]
well michelle you're a saint thank you
so much for calling in and thanks for
being honest
you got a hard road to hoe and a blessed
road to hoe and it's the same it's both
and and it's a mess and it's
chaos and it's joy
and um thanks for calling and trusting
with us trusting with us trusting us
even uh even me